The whole world was looking for the next Iron Man. I don't know if I can live up to that
I don't think Tony would have done what he did if he didn't know that you were gonna be here after he was gone
We have a job to do you're coming looks can you give that to MJ if you something happens to me?
You got this Stark made you an Avenger the world needs that
Everywhere I go I see his face
She's really missing. Yeah, I miss him too.
I don't think Tony would have done what he did if he didn't know that you were going to be here after he was gone
You gonna be a next Iron Man now? Well, no, I don't have time I'm too busy doing your jobs. Oh I'm kidding
I'm kidding look keep up the good work because I am going on vacation
Heads up Nick Fury's calling you. I
Don't really want to talk to me resolve
Why because if you don't talk to him and I have to talk I don't want to talk about
You sent Nick Fury to voicemail. I gotta go you do not ghost Nick Fury
Dorks, what's up? We're just talking about the trip. I'm here
Oh, I think MJ really likes me. Come on when I first went alone
You're a very difficult person to contact spider-man
This is mr. Beck
We're gonna use someone like you on my world new world Beck is from Earth
Just not ours a snap to our home in our dimension
We have a job to do you're coming with us
It's gotta be something else you can use What about Thor ? Offworld ! Captain Marvel ? Unavailable !
But who's the friendly neighborhood spider-man
Bitch please you've been to space
What do you want Peter? I?
Want to go back on my trip with the girl who I really like and tell her how I feel MJ. I am spider-man
No, of course not. I mean it's kind of obvious
You're right. You may not be ready. But this is my responsibility
Saving the world requires sacrifice
Sometimes people die
I always feel like I'm putting my friends in danger the world needs next Iron Man
You going to step up or not
Here building jet I work with spider-man. You work for Spider man? I work with Spider man not for Spider man